Saturdays are a big day to dine out but
an increasing number of people are
opting to stay home and order in
according to a recent study revenue from
deliveries is up 20 percent in the past
five years with the number of deliveries
up ten percent overall surprisingly the
biggest demand is for breakfast and
lunch now the drive is fueled in large
part by the rise of third-party services
or apps such as GrubHub seamless
ubereats and even doordash they take the
orders online for the restaurants and
deliver the food those restaurants have
taken notice and are even changing the
way they do business from the frying pan
to the front door that's the new mantra
for many diners no matter what they're
eating
just ask bone Appetit editor-in-chief
Adam Rapoport we used to think Pizza
Chinese food that's delivery that has
changed a lot you can pretty much
literally get anything you want
deliver now it's ready to eat like a
restaurant but at home people are still
buying the goods they just want it to
come to them instead of them going to it
mimi blitz is counting on it blitz open
pinky space in New York City's East
Village with co-owner and chef Wesley
waffles earlier this year but don't
expect to sit and eat here it's either
takeout or delivery we wanted to create
happy meals for adults the game was to
have a small footprint in the city so
you know keeps costs down and focusing
on the delivery and the takeout the same
food you could get in a restaurant but
truly in your own exactly yes pinky
space serves up what blitz called a
hybrid of southern and French cuisine
things like brisket and roast turkey are
staples they keep the menu simple to
help and delivery which blitz says is 75
to 80 percent of their business with a
unique space and few setting foot in it
blitzes next goal delivering the
atmosphere along with the food how do
you take this space and bring it to
somebody at home our packaging I think
we've got our packaging here we bring in
a lot of color most restaurants they
just put it in the same kind of to-go
container
and we really wanted to stand out even
more you go into the restaurant you sit
down it's all about the ambience you
know in a way our packaging brings our
ambience to your home the actual
delivery made easier thanks to apps like
seamless GrubHub and ubereats
with most providing not just the
ordering platform but also the delivery
personnel nearly 3,000 miles away in Los
Angeles chef Zach [ __ ] says those
same delivery services are also helping
change the restaurant game to do your
own in-house delivery wood it's a real
undertaking but then suddenly there's
this like option of you know seamless or
caviar they take a commission obviously
but they make your life a little easy
they make your life a little easier and
they allow us to serve a community that
otherwise we just don't have the
resources or the infrastructure or the
experience to do Pollock owns two
restaurants in LA his latest cosa buona
which he designed keeping an evolving
restaurant industry in mind how much of
the business here is delivering about
half of it leaves the front door 4 years
ago when you opened your first
restaurant would you have thought that
delivery would be as important as it is
now I probably would not have when I
opened it I was much more concerned with
you know just the diner's experience
within these four walls as I looked at
like the reality of this industry is not
just a creative process but also a
business delivery became a little bit
more interesting so as a chef he
tailored his menu to better serve the
delivery diner items range from pizza to
clams and octopus the menu is designed
to be delicious whether it hits a table
in 30 seconds or you know hits your
apartment dining room table in an hour
and a half we have like a grilled
broccolini here we put the bread crumbs
on immediately by the time that gets
there they're gonna be soggy and awful
so it's compartmentalized um the bread
crumbs they have the same my crunchy
experience that you would if you were
dining at the restaurant Pollock says
the delivery business has also picked up
at his other restaurant leaving him with
another challenge how is a chef
a restaurant owner do you make sure
people are still coming in and not just
looking to have everything deliver
that's a good question I think that I
think people still go out for a very
different reason people come to
restaurants to you know engage with
friends of theirs to engage peripherally
with strangers to be served I think that
will never be replaced
Bon Appetit Adam Rapoport agrees I think
what the restaurants have going for them
is they've got good lighting good music
they've got vibes
they've got service they got a cocktail
list we're not getting that at home the
difference now is when we're at home
we're eating better than we were before
I'll tell you what it's dangerous for is
dangerous for our pocketbooks ordering
in has become an increasingly fancier
option it's no longer the cheap and easy
thing to do it's easy but it's not cheap
how on earth did they discover that
delivery was in demand it it's the apps
I mean it is just all about the apps
that changed everything both sides it's
easier for you the customer you get
online you don't have to talk to anybody
you order and for them they can mark
things that are no longer offered and
they don't have to worry about the
delivery personality it really has
changed the game I want a list of
cocktails at home